[Music]
lincoln's with us in dayton ohio hey
lincoln what's up
hey dave thank you so much for all that
you guys do um
i
we
my wife and i i am 27 and my wife's 24
and we have paid off about 30 000 worth
of debt since november right but we
still have we still have 40 000 more and
she's actually going back to get her
master's in education
and she wants to
basically the main premise of my
question is my wife likes to upgrade a
lot of things very quickly
and she likes paying off debt but not to
the point where she doesn't get what she
wants and so it leads up to me having to
um having to say no to a lot of a lot of
decisions on things that she wants and i
feel like a parent in our marriage i
don't want to feel like a parent to my
wife um so i don't know if you have any
insight on that well
i sense that you're you're feeling some
resentment towards her because you don't
want to baby her but i want to have you
look in the mirror and go maybe i
haven't done a good job getting us on
the same page
i mean is that not the problem you're
not on the same page when it comes to
what your goals are and then what our
actions are to get there
yeah that could definitely be a fair
point it's hard to get other people to
be excited
it's hard to get other people to be
excited about your goal this ain't her
goal it's your goal
yeah her goals upgrades that is fair
so george was right so i would i would
have a conversation with her and go hey
listen i know you want to do these
upgrades and i love that i want to do
that but i want to do it the right way
and i want us to get out of debt first
because this is how it's going to propel
us forward and get us there even faster
without any stress or anxiety and now
she goes oh he wants the same thing i
want now we can start moving in the same
direction
yeah that's good and then uh she's also
so she's going back and getting her
masters right now in education um why is
she doing that just curious what's the
end goal of getting the math you got it
she got a degree in hr and after a few
months she decided that she didn't like
her job in hr so then she
took a
she is basically an aide for a special
education room and that she decided
that's what she wants to do so she has
to get her teaching degree in order to
do that it was the same price to get her
masters as it was the undergrad
yeah
and so she's already quit her job
yeah that was about six months ago and
so it was taking less money and then
also adding up more debt and that
doesn't feel like we're moving towards
the same goal um so when george said
that i was like kind of iffy on it
because there are like other symptoms in
this uh scenario of
her wanting her not being all in for
the ramsay plan it's not the ramsay plan
dude it's the lincoln and his wife plan
you gotta decide what that is
and so here's the thing okay
this is not a this is not a um financial
question it's more of a marriage
question but
the um the deal at our house is
that we both have to be in agreement
and we both have a vote
my vote's not bigger than hers her
vote's not bigger than mine
her dreams are not bigger than mine my
dreams are not bigger than hers we both
have to be in agreement before we make
major decisions
so you don't quit your job without both
of us talking about it
um unless you're sexually assaulted at
work you know and then you can quit your
job and walk out and tell me about it
right but i mean just because you
changed your mind to 24 years old three
months after you got out of college that
you didn't like your job and your whole
career path and so you change it and
going to go back to school again to fix
this oh brother so no we don't do that
stuff we don't we don't upgrade in this
we don't not do this we don't go pay off
big debts we don't we don't make big
decisions but we're both together and
that forces us to back up from the
actual decision itself and say is this
decision taking us
the fastest possible way
to our goal and are we in agreement of
our goal
and so sharon and i just don't make
decisions that way and so in your case
in other words she's got shane's got a
veto card she goes i'm not going along
with this okay and we're not doing it
until we talk it through and we see
where it fits
and um
very seldom does she do that very seldom
do i say no not going along with that i
don't agree with that
and that vetoes it stops
and it's not you telling her what to do
or she telling you what to do but you
both have a vote you have the ability to
stop the train if the train's off the
tracks
and y'all aren't doing that she's just
doing whatever the flip she wants to do
and you feel ballsy